شكرا للزميل طالب اهلا بكم الى هذه الساعه
الاخباريه من تغطيتنا المتواصله لتطورات
الاوضاع في السودان اشتباكات مستمره لليوم
الثالث على التوالي وبيانات وتصريحات
متضاربه حول مناطق السيطره او الخسائر
مبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون اخر المواقع التي
يشهد ادعاءات سيطره كلا الطرفين قاعده
مروي هي الاخرى لا تزال مسرحا لتبادل
اطلاق النار بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
كما هو الحال في محيط قياده الجيش في
العاصمه الخرطوم سياسيا ومع تصاعد الدعوات
الدوليه المطالبه بحل الازمه ونزع فتيلها
قالت الخارجيه السودانيه في بيان لها
اليوم ان الوضع الراهنه شان داخل
والسودانيون سيتوصلون الى التسويه بانفسهم
[موسيقى]
اذا تتواصل الاشتباكات في محيط القياده
العامه للجيش بالعاصمه الخرطوم ويقع مقر
القياده العامه في المنطقه الشماليه من
العاصمه على بعد نحو اربعه كيلومترات فقط
من مطار الخرطوم كما يتواجد بالقرب من مقر
قياده القوات البحريه ورئاسه اركان القوات
الجويه ويعد مقر القياده العامه مركزا
مهما وحساسا بالنسبه لقوات الجيش السوداني
ويستمر اطلاق الرصاص في محيط المبنى مع
تداول اخبار عن استخدام اسلحه ثقيله
خلوها قبضناها
ماشيه حيه ماشيه حيه فلل
زي ما قاعد تقولوا اسرع ربطكم في فتيلنا
كويس الله اكبر الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
رباط الدعم السريع في قبضه القوات المسلحه
بالكامل اكثر من 15 كروزر رساله لايجه
رساله لايليشيا
اكد الناطقوا باسم الجيش السوداني للعربيه
انما يجري في السودان هو اشتباكات متقطعه
تحاول من خلالها قوات الدعم السريع اقتحام
المقرات العسكريه بالاضافه الى عمليات قنص
واستهداف لعدد من ضباط الجيش السوداني
طبيعه الاحداث التي
تحدث منذ الاول من امس هي
اشتباكات ومحاولات اقتحامات بعدد من
المقرات العسكريه نحن نتصدى لهذه
المحاولات
واضافه الى ان هنالك عمليات قنص واستهداف
لضباطنا وجنودنا لذلك تم جرت محاولات
لاعتقاد والقبض على
افرادنا ضباطنا وجنودنا اذا عرفوه الى
مواقعهم مواقع عملهم الرسميه ثم
القبض على واقول اسف اما القبض على العديد
من الضباط الذين همارسون في دور
مثلا قيمه على الاستخبارات او ضباط توجهوا
الى مواقع عملهم في الصباح تم اعتقالهم
واعتبارهم جذوع بشريه في مقرات ميليشيا
الدعم السريع
اشتباكات اليوم محدوده جدا اقل عده بكثير
من اليوم الاول من الامس نحن نعصر عمليات
نا المرحله في التصدي لمحاولاتهم اقتحام
بعض المواقع مقرات القوات المسلحه في محيط
القياده العامه لجميع مقرات القياده
العامه هي الان تحت سيطره القياده العامه
كما نفى العميد نبيل عبد الله الناطق باسم
الجيش السوداني للعربيه ادعاءات قوات دعم
السريع بالسيطره على اجزاء من مبنى
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه والقصر
الجمهوري وقصر الضيافه
نؤكد انه لا صح اطلاقا
باستيلاء او سيطره مديشيا الدعم السريع
المتمرده على اي من مقرات القياده العامه
ولا على قصر الضيافه ولا على القطر
الجمهوري هذه التهذيب مضلله الامر الثاني
نحن نؤكد اننا القوات المسلحه لاننا قوات
محترفه وقوات مسؤوله ونحن نلتزم تماما
بجميع قواعد الاشتباك في مثل هذه الحالات
نحن نتقيد تماما بمقررات القانون الدولي
الانساني قانون النزاعات المسلحه في هذا
النزاع المسلح
في المقابل رد يوسف عزه المستشار السياسي
لقائد قوات الدعم السريع على تصريحات
الناطق باسم الجيش مؤكدا للعربيه سيطره
الدعم السريع على القصر الجمهوري ومقرات
القياده العامه
نحن نسيطر على القصر الجمهوري نحن نسيطر
على كل
المقال وزارات
خرطوم الكباري كافه الكباري
التي تربط بين الخرطوم والمدير الثلاثه
نحن فقط عبر هذه الغنم المواطنين ان هنالك
دعايه ان الدعم السريع يعتدي على مواطنين
او ينهب ممتلكاتهم هذه دعايه رخيصه نحن
نؤمن المواطنين ويشهد بذلك كل المواطنين
في الشارع نوع من المواطنين نعم من
المغاربه التي نستلمها ولا ندخلها ولا
نعتدي على وثائقها ولا على اوراقها
هذا مطالب قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد
حمدان دقلو عبر سلسله تغريدات نقلتها
وكاله رويترز عن حساب في تويتر طلب
المجتمع الدولي بالتحرك الفوري والتدخل ضد
ما اسماها بجرائم رئيس مجلس سياده
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان
[موسيقى]
من مدينه مروي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
نزار بقداوي نزار مرحبا بك معي في هذه
الساعه
نزار الصوره الاوضاع في محيط هذه
القاعده كيف تبدو حتى هذه اللحظه
الاشتباكات كيف يمكن تقييمها ايضا كذلك
تحيه ساترك الصوره
لتعطي مزيد من التفاصيل وبدوري سادلي بما
يتوفر الان من معلومات حول طبيعه المشهد
العسكري والامني والطبيعه العمليات
الحربيه والعسكريه والاشتباكات التي
طيب يبدو اننا فقدنا الصوره قاعده الجويه
العسكريه اتصالات
الانترنت وشبكه الانترنت من السودان
انقطاع ثم عوده عوده ثم انقطاع نزار هل
تسمعني الان
طيب يبدو انا اسمع طيب نعم نحن نراك لكن
الصوره يعني
الصوره
لم تعد حتى هذه اللحظه وربما ان هذه صور
متفرقه من قاعده مروي نزار تفضل اليك
الكلمه
نعم انا نعم انا استمع نعم كما ذكرنا
طيب يبدو اننا نواجه مشكله مع الزميل
النزار سنعود اليه حاله ما جهز هذا
المباشر صوتا وصوره للوقوف على اخر
مستجدات
محيط القاعده العسكريه في مروي وكذلك
المطار الملحق بها ايضا
اذا اصدر رئيس مجلس السياده قائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان قرارا بحل الدعم
السريع واعلانه قوه متمرده على الدوله
وذلك بحسب بيان وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه
كما اكدت الخارجيه ان كل الوساطات الوطنيه
لدمج الدعم السريع بالجيش قد باءت بالفشل
جاء في البيان ايضا ان الجيش يعتمد
استراتيجيه قتاليه
لتقليل الخسائر
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
في الجيش السوداني للعربيه ما تم نشره من
قبل قوات الدعم السريع حول اقتحام مقر
اقامه البرهان واكد المصدر للعربيه ان
الاشتباك جرت حول مقري البرهان وحميتي وتم
ابعاد هذه القوات وان فيديو اقتحام الدعم
السريع لمقر البرهان مضلل وغير حقيقي
يتصارعوا في نقب الدوله
والشراب والتعليم والعلاج
اطباء السودان صراع على السلطه بين طرفي
النزاع مع خروج مستشفيات اعده من الخدمه
تماما ابرزها مستشفى الشعب التعليمي
والخرطوم التعليمي وقالت النقابه ان قصف
المرافق الصحيه يعد انتهاكا واضحا للقانون
الدولي الانساني والمواثي ذات الصله
ومن مدينه مروي عهود الينا مراسل العربيه
نزار بقداوي نزار مرحبا بك من جديد هل
تسمعني الان اولا
نزار
طيب لا زالت المشكله من المصدر طبعا في
الاتصالات من السودان سواء كانت البث
المباشر او حتى الاتصالات الهاتفيه سنحاول
معالجه هذا هذا
الخلل ومن بعد ذلك سنعود الى زميل نزار
بقداوي اذا تعرض مستشفى ابن سينا وهو احد
اكبر المستشفيات في العاصمه الخرطوم الى
اضرار بالغه في بعض مباني بعض سقوط قذائف
عشوائيه عليه جراء الاشتباكات المستمره
والعنيفه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في
الخرطوم وبخلاف الاضرار التي تقع على
المستشفيات يجد الاطباء والمرضى صعوبات
كبيره في الوصول الى المستشفيات القريبه
من اماكن الاشتباك
من جديد الى مروي مراسل العربيه نزار
مرحبا بك معي من جديد الاوضاع في محيط
مروي كيف يمكن تقييمها في هذه اللحظات
نزار
اولا هذا الصوت واضح بالنسبه لك دائما
واضح تفضل
تشاهدها الان كانت مسرحا قبل ساعتين من
الان
لاشتباكات مسلحه بين الجيش وبين الكعبه
السريع
من هذا الموقع ومن مواقع اخرى داخل مدينه
مروي اعمده والسنه الدخان تتصاعد من هذه
القاعده ومن هذا المطار
فسر هذا الامر عبر المعلومات وعبر المصادر
ان اشتباكات اراد عبرها الجيش السوداني ان
يعيد حسب ما فهمنا السيطره
القاعده بعد ان اعلن ذاته الجيش بان قوات
الدعم السريع قد وصلت صباح اليوم الى هذه
القاعده والى هذا المطار الان الامور
هادئه في محيط لا نستمع حتى الان الى
اصوات الرصاص الى مدفعيه ثقيله الاوضاع
هادئه مدينه مروي
الان في المدينه الطرق خالي
تمركزات الجيش السوداني القوات المسلحه
من المحاور لكن لاشتباكات داخل المدينه
لعمليات عسكريه داخل المدينه كل ما دار
وسيدور سيكون فقط في محيط القاعده والمطار
الدولي
كانت هناك انباء يعني واخبار متداوله في
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي خصوصا السودانيه
تتحدث عن يعني اخبار لتسلل او هروب لعدد
من افراد قوات الدعم السريع ممن يتواجدون
داخل هذه القاعده قاعده مروي العسكريه هل
لديكم اي معلومات تاكيدات او نفي نزار
لا معلومات صراحه ولا معلومات حقيقه حول
طبيعه هذه
المعلومات وهذه التسريبات وهذه البيانات
كل ما يدور الان وكل ما نعرفه انها الان
اصبحت مسرح لحرب في عمليه عسكريه عمليه
استرداد عمليه خروج ومن ثم دخول كل هذه
الفرضيات وكل هذه
التكتيكات العسكريه تطرح كثير من
التساؤلات لكن المعلومه المؤكد ان هذه
المساحه التي تشاهدونها الان حصريا على
العربيه هي مسرح لعمليه عسكريه هي مسرح
الاشتباكات بدات قبل ثلاثه ايام في اليوم
الاول استمرت في اليوم الثاني فهذا اليوم
الثالث حادثه قبل ساعتين والتوقعات تشير
الى انها ربما تتجدد خلال
قوه الساعات المقبله
طيب الاسناد الامداد العسكري ايضا للجيش
السوداني هل وصل الى محيط هذه القاعده او
اي امداد عسكري ايضا بالنسبه لقوات الدعم
السريع
في محيط القياده او في محيط القاعده
العسكريه هي الوصول الى تلك المنطقه
نتاكد من وجود دعم او سنه لكل الطرفين
ولكن ما نعرفه وما نتاكد من ان القياده
العسكريه هنا في هذه المنطقه قالت قبلا
للعربيه بانها على قدر الاستعداد للتعاطي
والتعامل مع شتى السيناريوهات التي تفرضها
هذه العمليه وصفتها بانها عمليه عسكريه
قالت وذكرت بانها ستتعامل وستتعاطى
بكافه الاشكال حتى تتمكن
السيطره على كل المنافذ والمخارج وحتى
تجعل هذا المطار خالصا تماما في يد القوات
المسلحه
نزار يعني متى كانت المره الاخيره يعني
التي
سمع فيها ربما دوي اطلاق الرصاص او
انفجارات ايضا او اشتباكات بالقرب منك في
محيط القاعده العسكريه في مروي
على نحو الساعه ونصف او ساعتين استمعنا
وشاهدنا
ارتفاع لاعمده الدخان من هذه القاعده
واستمعنا ايضا الى ذوي واستمعنا الى
اشتراكات بين الفينه والاخرى نستمع الى
تخاطر الرصاص لا ندري في اي اتجاه اطلقت
ولكن نستمع في فترات متقطعه
كل ما يحدث الان هو يشير
ويدفع الى ان العمليه هي مستمره
طالما ان قوات الدعم السريع بحسب الجيش ما
زالت في القاعده فهذا يعني وفق الكثيرين
هنا تحديدا العسكريين بان العمليه
العسكريه ستمضي وستستمر طيب بالنسبه
للمواطنين للسكان الاهالي اهالي مروي كيف
يتعاملون مع هذا الوضع القائم الان في
مروي وبالقرب من
القاعده يعني ممن هم قريبون اكثر من
القاعده العسكريه
مدينه
تعيش لاكثر من ثلاثه ايام حاله من التمر
او الخوف والترقب لما الات عمليه عسكريه
بدات قبل ثلاثه ايام وما زالت مستمره
بتداعيات وبمستويات متعدده ومختلفه هم
يعيشون هذه التفاصيل الدقيقه بدقيقه
في منازلهم في مساء الاحتياجات الضروريه
متوفره حتى
الان لا ازمه غذاء في المدينه
بشيء لكنها
عادت الى او بعض الاحياء الطرقات سالته
للحركه الخدمه المدنيه متوفره المستشفى
الرئيس يعمل في هذه المدينه حتى كان ليس
هنالك حديث عن ازمه انسانيه عن نزوح
لمواطنين من هذه المدينه الى مناطق اخرى
الاوضاع يمكن
ان نكون مستتبه ومستقره حتى الان
جزيلا لك على كل هذه
المعلومات التي نقلتها الينا النزار
بقداوي مراسل العربيه من مدينه مروي
في هذه الاثناء اعلنت نقابه اطباء السودان
ارتفاع حصيله ضحايا الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع الى 97 قتيلا وفق
البيان فان عدد القتلى يتجاوز هذه الحصيله
لاسيما وان الكثير منهم لم ينقلوا الى
المستشفيات اما بسبب الوضع الحرجي او
صعوبه في التنقل
[موسيقى]
ومعنا من الخرطوم رئيس لجنه تا سياسات في
حزب الامه القومي السوداني امام الحلو
سيدي امام مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه
اولا كيف تقراون المشهد السوداني
الحالي من جانبكم الى اين يتجه بدايه
اهلا وسهلا مرحبا في قناه العربيه مشهد
السوداني الان ماساوي ومشهد
انساني يعني الان
الخرطوم في حال مزريه من الدمار نتيجه
لهذه الاشتباكات العباسيه
الاشتباكات العسكريه
ونحن الان في وضع سيء جدا في كل مناحي
الحياه مستشفيات الان
تعطلت خدمات الاساسيه تعطلت الان من
كهرباء ومياه طرق مقفوله ومرضى وانا في
البدايه لابد ان نترحم على الشهدائنا من
المدنيين والعسكريين الذين فقدوا ارواحهم
في خلال الايام الماضيه
ووضع على مسائل وماساوي شديد يعني طيب هل
اعدتم التواصل مع طرفي الازمه البرهان
وحميتي ام لازلتم غير قادرين على الوصول
اليهم او حتى يعني التواصل معهم شخصي
نحن عندنا اجهزه تتواصل
مع كل اطراف النزاع على مستوى القيادات
والان نحن كما تعلم طرحنا مبادره بتشكيل
لينه من الاطراف
طرفين نزاع
بالاضافه الى شخصيات قوميه حددنا العدد
الخمسه ونعمل على ذلك الان
ونامل انه يتم التوصل لهذا الاتفاق سريعا
ولكن الان
اولوياتنا هي وقف هذا القتال وقف هذا
الاشتباكات في داخل المدن يعني نريد ان
نعرف اول هل هل استجاب لكم البرهان وحمتها
هل تواصلتم معهم شخصيا ام لم تنجحوا في
الوصول اليهم حتى الان
نعم تواصلنا ولكن لم تنجح حتى الان في
تواصل ولكن لم تنجح حتى الان الاستجابه
لوقف نحن اتصالاتنا لوقف هذا القتال في
الاساس بماذا ردوا عليكم
الان في معرفه الان هم يتحدثوا عن معرفه
وده طبعا
نتيجه لهذا الوضع
الاشتباك العسكري يزعم الحديث عن حكمه
ولذلك نحن الان قياده الطرفين
بوقف القتال الان المهمه الان وقف هذا
الاصطدام العسكري الان ثم ننتقل الى مرحله
اخرى في معالجه هذه الاختلافات سيناريو
الحرب الاهليه كنتم في حزب الامه حذرتم
منه في اكثر من مناسبه هل هناك من مؤشر
لاقتراب هذا الخطر دخول المدنيين على خط
هذه الازمه والاشتباكات بان يكون طرف
والسياسيه
ندعو الى وقف القتال ما بين
القوات المسلحه والدعم السريع ولا اعتقد
انه اي قوه مدنيه ستنحاز الان لانه هذا
خطا اساسي القضيه قضيه وطنيه ولابد من انه
الوقوف النزيف الدم ثم استعاده الحياه
الطبيعيه في المدن خاصه في الخرطوم ثم
المرحله الثالثه كيفيه التوصل الى تسويه
بين الطرفين ثم ننتقل الى مرحله رابعه وهو
الحياه المدنيه في السودان هذه هي
اولوياتنا بصوره واضحه جدا ولذلك التحركنا
الان في حزب الامه في الترتيبات اللي انا
ذكرتها نحن الان لا نتحدث عن اي عمل سياسي
الان مهمتنا هي
الوقف الاقتتال وتثبيت الامن في كافه ربوع
السودان ثم ننظر استعاده الحياه الطبيعيه
الان
في تدمير في كافه مناحيه ثم نمره ثلاثه
ننتقل العمل السياسي والتسويه السياسيه
الان ليست اولويه يا عزيزيه الان الوضع
الخارجيه السودانيه كانت اليوم قد اعلنت
يعني بشكل ولو غير مباشر رفضه لاي
وسطات يعني في هذا الشان وقلت بان التسويه
يجب ان تكون بين السودانيين انفسهم لذلك
يعني هناك من يتحدث عن موقف سياسي بين كل
الاحزاب السودانيه موقف سياسي مدني موحد
في
الازمه اليوم هل هناك تنسيق للمواقف ما
بينكم وبين كل الاحزاب المدنيه السودانيه
يعني انتم تحتاجون الى دعم الدولي في وقف
الاقتتال لكن في التسويه السياسيه لا
تحتاجون الى اي دعم دولي لا تحتاجون ايضا
حتى لاي وسيط بينكم هكذا نفعل
نعم صحيح نحن بالوضوح وضوح الشديد نحن
نحتاج الان الان الى دعم دولي واقليمي
لوقف هذا
وكذلك نرفض اي تدخل عسكري اجنبي من اي
دوله من جيراننا او من غير جيراننا الان
نحن فقط نطالب بوقف هذا
الاشتباكات العسكريه ووقف هذا الاقتتال ثم
نحن كن سودانيين نستطيع ان نجلس لمعالجه
القضيه السياسيه والاختلافات ما بين
الطرفين هو ولذلك الصوره واضحه عندنا
تماما قبل انتلاء هذا الاقتتال باسبوع
تقريبا قلتم في حزب الامه القومي بان
العمليه السياسيه اقتربت من نهايتها
ما الذي تغير ما الذي قلب الامور راسا على
عقب ووصلت الى ما وصلت اليه الان
نعم نحن صحيح في مسيره العمليه السياسيه
توصلنا تقريبا الى مسوده الاتفاق النهائي
الاتفاق النهائي هو النسخه النهائيه
للاتفاق للاتفاق الايطالي الذي تم في خمسه
ديسمبر الماضي
وتم ورش بعد ذلك في قضايا اساسيه
وبناء عليه يتم توقيع اتفاق نهائي ما بين
المكون المدني والمكون العسكري اللي هو
المكون العسكري الان من الطرفين
المتنازعين الحين الان هذه الاتفاق
النهائي ده مسدته متفق ولكن كان في اختلاف
ما بين الفصلين المتسارعين القوات المسلحه
والدعم السريع فيما يتعلق في بعض القضايا
الفنيه وانا اعتقد انه هناك جهه ثالثه
مستفيده من هذا الصراع هي اللي اجت واللي
هي يعني سعت لتوسيع الشقه بين الطرفين
المتنازعين الان
وسعه يعني دعم عدم الثقه المتوفر فيها
مستفيده من هذا الوضع في محاوله وانا
بتحديد اتحدث عن مؤتمر الوطني
الحزب الداعم لنظام الانقاذ الباقي ولذلك
الان المستفيده الوحيد من دمار النظام
الان الانتقالي ومن دمار البنيه للدوله
نفسها هو
القوه الرده
المتمثله في المؤتمر الوطني
والقوه اللي دعم نظام الانقاذ البيت وما
في اي جهه ثانيه مستفيده من هذا الصراع
الدامي اللي بنفقد فيه ابنائنا بنفرد فيه
مقدرات البلد الان في دمار
الارواح وللممتلكات في داخل السودان هذا
يستفيد منه الناس اللي عايزين يستعيذوا
نظام البيت وانا بقول لهم لن يحدث هذا
الامر لانه الشعب السوداني حدد مواقفه
تماما من النظام البارد ومن عشره الحياه
السياسيه السودانيه نحن الان ننتقل من هذه
المرحله الى مدنيه كامله وثم نعود الى
الحياه السياسيه الطبيعيه ان شاء الله بعد
هذه الازمه
ان شاء الله شكرا جزيلا لك من الخرطوم
رئيس اللجنه السياسات في حزب الامه القومي
السوداني امام
اذا لا زالت مشاهدينا الكرام هذه الاصوات
تسمع اسماء تسمع طبعا هذه الاصوات في محيط
القياده العملي الجيش السوداني اصوات طبعا
اطلاق النار الكثيف تصاعد اعمده الدخان
ايضا كذلك في هذه المنطقه القريبه من
القياده العامه
للجيش بالعاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم كما نشاهد في هذه
الصوره كما نسمع ايضا دوي اطلاق النار
الرصاص
والمدفعيه ايضا سمعت في اكثر من
يعني مكان بالقرب من القياده العملي
القوات المسلحه كما نشاهد الان ايضا كذلك
اعمده الدخان وهي تتصاعد فوق سماء العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم واحتدام هذه الاشتباكات
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع قبل
قليل يتحدث مراسل العربيه نزار بقداوي من
منطقه اخرى في قاعده مروي بان هناك هدوء
حذر في محيط القاعده تحدث عن انتشار
تمركزات عسكريه لطرفي الصراع لكن الصوره
ايضا في الخرطوم يعني تبدو كما نشاهد
الان على الشاشه صوره الاشتباكات تتجدد
متقطعه هذه الاشتباكات كما نقل لنا مراسل
العربيه في اكثر من
فتره اخباريه سابقه بين الاشتباكات يعني
ليست مستمره تتقطع تعود
وتخفت لبعض الشيء الان هذه الصوره كما
ذكرنا من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم لسماع
ذوي اطلاق الرصاص واستخدام بعض الاسلحه
الثقيله والمدفعيه بالقرب من المحيط محيط
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
اذا تتواصل الاشتباكات في محيط القياده
العامه للجيش بالعاصمه الخرطوم ويقع مقر
القياده العامه في المنطقه الشماليه من
العاصمه على بعد نحو اربعه كيلو مترات فقط
من مطار الخرطوم كما يتواجد بالقرب من مقر
قياده القوات البحريه ورئاسه اركان القوات
الجويه ويعد مقر القياده العامه مركزا
وحساسا بالنسبه لقوات الجيش السوداني
ويستمر اطلاق الرصاص في محيط المبنى مع
تداول اخبار عن استخدام اسلحه ثقيله
اظهرت مقاطع فيديو صورا تظهر معاناه نحو
450 طالبا محتجزين بمدرسه بمدرسه كومبوني
منذ اندلاع الاشتباكات في الخرطوم الاطفال
المحتجزون يطالبون الحكومه السودانيه
بالوصول الى عائلاتهم وتوفير مواد غذائيه
ومياه شرب
في مجموعه من الطلاب الغين في مدرسه
الحاصل تقريبا كلهم عددهم 450 طالب
الاستاذ كله
من اخرتهم ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم مرحبا بك معي في هذه الساعه
يعني قبل قليل كنا نسمع ذوي اطلاق الرصاص
يعني مكثف بالقرب من القياده العامه
للقوات
المسلحه هل من معلومات لديك كيف هي
الاوضاع بشكل عام في الخرطوم سالم
ليست القياده اهلا وسهلا بك وبكل الساده
المشاهدين ليست القياده العامه وحدها من
يسمع فيها دوري الرصاص نحن هنا في منطقه
كافوري والان نستمع الى درصاص في هذه
المنطقه بين كافوري عفوا وبين
كافوريا فيها اشتباك منذ الصباح وذكر شهود
عيان ان هناك طيران قصف مناطق في منطقه
كافوري وايضا منطقه كوبرا التي نستمع الى
الادويه الرصاص منها الان من هذه المنطقه
من منطقه كوبر تحركنا من عبر هذا الشارع
الى ان وصلنا الى الجسر الذي يربط بين
الخرطوم وبحري جسر كوبر والذي
بجانبه او احداث عسكريه وكذلك سجن كوبر
وكذلك ايضا جهاز المخابرات العامه كل هذه
المنطقه فيها وحدات عسكريه هي منطقه
عسكريه بالقرب من هذا الجسر يسر كوبرا اذا
وصلنا الى جسر كوبر الحركه تبدو طبيعيه
الى حد ما ليست الحركه الطبيعيه العاديه
لكنها الى حد ما طبيعيه ليس هناك اي مظاهر
عسكريه في هذا
عن طريق حتى الجسر لكن مع ذلك بالقرب من
الجسر وليس ببعيد منه تستمع الى هذه
الاعينه الناريه التي نستمع اليها الان
الان نستمع الى هذه الأعير الناريه الى
القنابل الى المقذوفات ونحن الان في هذا
المباشر قبل ان ندخل اليك هناك مقذوفات
كانت من جهه كوبر الى جهه كافوري هذه
المقذوفات لا ندري من اي انواع الاسلحه
هذه لكن رايناها في الهواء قبل قليل طيب
لجنه اطباء السودانيين اطباء سودان عفوا
كانت قد تحدثت عن اكثر من مئه قتيل ما بين
او اكثر من 100 قتيل مدني طبعا قتلوا في
هذه الاشتباكات داخل الخرطومه خارجها اسال
هنا عن الاوضاع
الطبيه اوضاع المستشفيات كذلك سالم كيف
يمكن تقييمها من خلال وجودك على الارض في
العاصمه الخرطوم
نعم لجنه الاطباء السودان المركزيه ترسل
نداءات منذ بدايه هذه الازمه وهي تتحدث عن
هذه النداءات الانسانيه وفتح الممرات
الامنه لو تشاهد خلف الان ايضا كان هناك
انفجار في هذه المنطقه هذه اعمده اللهب
التي تتصاعد لم يتم احتواء هذا الحريق حتى
الان لا ندري ما هو سببه بالضبط ونحن
قادمون الى هنا راينا ونعود الى موضوع
لجنه اطباء السودان المركزيه والوضع
الانساني مركزيه ظلت تنادي وتناشد منظمات
المجتمع الدولي ومنظمات المجتمع المدني
والمنظمات الدوليه كذلك
يبدو اننا فقدنا
الزميل وفقدنا صوت وصوره الزميل سالم
الهاشمي سالم هل تسمعني
هل تسمعني نعم اسمعك جيدا تفضل كنت تتحدث
عن الاوضاع الانسانيه في السودان في
الخرطوم تحديدا نعم تتحدث لجنه اطباء
السودان الم على انه يجب فتح ممرات امنه
او هدنه يشهد عليها المجتمع الدولي لاجل
ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه ووصول الكوادر
الطبيه الى المستشفىات خاصه بعد تاكد لنا
ان مستشفى الشعب مستشفى الخرطوم الذي قالت
لجنه اطباء المركزيه انه خارج الخدمه الان
مستشفى ابن سينا تعرض لقصف كذلك في مبناه
ولم يتاثر
المقيمه او المتواجدون في المستشفى ابن
سينا باثار قويه الى حد ما لكن في كل
الاحوال هذه الاحداث كلها تدفع الى انه
يجب على الجانبان ان يوفر امام مرات امنه
او وقفهن لايصال هذه المساعدات ووصول
الكوادر الطبيه الى المستشفيات لتقديم
الدعم اللازم فيما يختص بالمصابين الذين
يتم عرضهم تباعا وايصالهم بشكل متواصل الى
المستشفيات الرئيسه مستشفى ام درمان
التعليمي وكذلك هنا في بحري في مستشفى بح
المستشفى المستشفى الدولي وردت اليه
العديد من الاصابات وسننطلق الى هذا
المستشفى بعد قليل شكرا جزيلا لك على كل
هذه المعلومات سنتابع معك في سياق هذه
النشره ونشراتنا القادمه في هذه التغطيه
الموسعه للملف السوداني من الخرطوم مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي شكرا جزيلا لك اذا
ومع التحليق المكثف للطائرات الحربيه
للجيش يبدو ان السيطره على القواعد
العسكريه الجويه الشغل الشاغل الان لدى
قوات الدعم السريع فسلاح الجو وفق عسكريين
هو النقطه الفاصله في المعركه بين الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع فمن يحكم السيطره
عليه يحسم المعركه نتابع
معركه السماء وان كان الهدف على الارض ففي
السودان القوه هنا في القواعد الجويه قوات
الدعم السريع التي لا تمتلك قوه جويه تعلم
ان من يمتلك الاجواء يحسم المعركه فكانت
البدايه من هنا حيث القوه
اشتعلت المعركه حين اقتحمت قوات حميتي
احدى القواعد الجويه في الخرطوم اشتبك
الطرفان استخدم الجيش ثلاث طائرات عسكريه
حتى الان خلال الاشتباك ضد قوات الدعم
السريع منذ انتشارها في قاعده مروي حيث
البدايه قاعده مروي الجويه تقع شمال
السودان تستخدم غالبا في التدريبات
والمناورات الجويه تاتي بعدها قاعده
الخرطوم وسط العاصمه وعلى غرب الخرطوم
هنالك قاعده الابيض شمال ولايه كردفان
وايضا قاعده وادي سيدنا في منطقه ام درمان
بالاجمال هناك ثمان قواعد جويه اهمها
بالنسبه للطرفين قاعده مروي لاحتوائها على
اكبر عدد من الطائرات واحدثها والاهم مركز
فعال للمراقبه والطائرات بدون طيار وتليها
اكبر قاعده وادي سيدنا وفيها مخاب ئ
الطائرات وعشرات المقاتلات العسكريه غذاء
السالم العربيه
ومعي هنا في الاستوديو الصحفي احمد
القرشي اهلا وسهلا فيك استاذ احمد منورنا
خلينا نسال في البدايه عن تضارب البيانات
التقارير
الاتهامات بالتضليل بين الطرفين ايضا ما
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع يعني الجيش
يقول بانه مسيطر على مثلا قصر الجمهوري
لكن قوات الدعم السريع تنفي ذلك تؤكد انها
هي من سيطره ويعني قس عليها ما الذي يعني
هذا الامر بالنسبه لما يحدث اليوم في
السودان هذا التضارب يعني الكثير ان هنالك
اضطرابا حقيقيا هنالك اشتباكات ترقى الى
يعني
حد النزاع ممكن نقول النزاعل اهل الدموي
والطرفين
كنا يتحذران لهذا النزاع لكن في نفس الوقت
انه لما وصلنا لمرحله
الاشتباك الح الامور معقده جدا جدا السبب
نايف انه الدعم السريع كان موجود في كل
مكان يعني تخيل انه الدعم السريع موجود في
الاذاعه موجود في التلفزيون موجود في
القصر للجمهوري يعني العدد كمن اكبر مرتين
من الجيش نفسه داخل يعني كان بيتواجد
بكثافه عاليه في وزاره العمل في وزاره
السياحه في منظمه المراه في يعني في كل
مكان يتواجد بكثافه اكثر من الجيش استاذ
احمد هذه يعني تلك كما يقولون يعني محنه
اخرى عقب الثوره في ديسمبر ونجاحه في
ديسمبر يعني نجاحها في ابريل جاءت قوات لم
كانت ممنوعه هذه القوات كانت ممنوعه من
دخول الخرطوم لكن بعدما انتصار او يعني
سقوط البشير في 12 ايوا
ابري 2019 هذه القوات دخلت
في دخلت الخرطوم العاصمه واصبحت تتقاسم مع
الجيش الاماكن واصبح يعني تتصرف كانها هي
قوه
موازيه للجيش الجيش موجود في اي مكان هي
توجد فيه بطبيعه الحال واصبح هناك في ربك
حول وضعها القانوني لذلك اليوم
هنالك ارتباك شديد القصر الجمهوري وهم
موجودين داخل القصر الجمهوري والجيش يقول
كما اعلم انه لا يريد ان يدمر القصر
الجمهوري يعني هم كميات عدد كبير منهم
موجود في القصر يعني
اكثر من
1500 1500 موجودين في القصر القديم والقصر
الجديد يعني في امتداد القصر في القصر
القديم في حوالي 1800 والبقيه في
الجمهوري الجديد
اللي هو من زمن الانجليز من
1899 موجود اصبح يعني شيء اثري وصاحب عليه
لكن هذا الاضطراب طبيعي انك انت سمحت وانا
اقول هذا الكلام واضح حتى انه ما تختلط
المفاهيم
والمصطلحات سمح لهذه القوات بان تكون
موجوده ولابد انه هذا فيه تحقيق انه كيف
سمح لقوه يعني انت عندك الشرطه لابد انه
تيجي لما تتخذ موقعك كقوه نظاميه بتتخذوا
اجراءات معينه بروتوكولات معينه لكن هذه
عشان كده تلقاه في القصر الجمهوري ثقافي
الاذاعه والتلفزيون تلقاه في الشوارع
تلقاه حتى في البيوت يعني جاءت سيطرت على
بيوت مثلا بيوت كثيره في الخرطوم كانت
تتبع كان يسكن فيها اتبع النظام السابق
مسؤولين وقاده عسكريين وكذا عندما سقط
نظام البشير وذهبوا يسيطر على هذه البيوت
وجلسوا فيها ومنذ اذ لم يتحرك ولذلك هذا
الخلط او الغموض عن الوضع ربما لهذا الشيء
لكن من ناحيه ثانيه من ناحيه عسكريه
الامور كما تقول القوات المسلحه والجيش
السوداني ودفع اعتقادي صحيح يعني هي ذاهبه
الى نهايه لكن خسائر
هي ذاهبه الى نهايه الكل يقول هذا الامر
الدعم السريع يقول بانه ذاهب الى نهايه
والجيش يقول بانه ذاهب الى نهايه لكن باي
شكل هذه النهايه كيف ستكون هل هي حتميه
قريبه هل سيكون هناك سقوط كبير لمدنيين
لعسكريين ستخلف الالاف من القتلى وبحتراب
من اهلي كما يقول البعض هذا هذا هذا الشيء
المرير الذي يعني
يوجع القلب
ويفطر يعني الفؤاد انه هنالك مدنيين
ومدنيين يعني من كل الفئات الان تجد اطباء
عمال
مهندسين عمال يوميا كثر من القتلى يعني
تجاوز العدد اكثر من 200 220 شخص في انحاء
متعدده ولم يزل هنالك قتله كثيرون لم
تصلوا بسبب انه الاقتتال عشوائي لم يصل
اليهما اهاليهم ولم يصل اليهم احبائهم هذه
هي المراره التي ستنجم عن هذا الموضوع لكن
عسكريا نحن نتحدث عن جيش نظامي استعاد
يعني انا شعرت
صحفي من متابع ودارس يعني يعني زي ما
بيقولوا هذه الخبره الطويله
الجيش السوداني امس استعاد
كنترول كاملا واضحا الاساسي انت لديك
مجموعه مجموعه الدعم السريع مجموعه لا
امداد لها
نحن الخرطوم والسوداني تتعرف واسع ما في
امداد يعني انت موجود داخل خرطوم اليوم
داخل القصر الرئاسي ما في امداد يوم يومين
انتهوا قضوا اليومين دول معناه خلاص وهل
هذا يعني انه الوضع في في مروي سينتهي
قريبا لانها حاصره مثلا في في القاعده
القاعده القاعده دلوقتي تم يعني
خلاص سيطر عليه الجيش كاملا يعني انتهت
يعني القوات اللي كانت موجوده هناك فرط
لانه صراحه كما نقول يعني انه اذا كان
الوحده المعينه لم تستطع ان عندها يعني
امداد الحياه هالمويه والاكل والشرب حتى
اندادات العسكريه يعني
كل الاشياء المتعلقه بانك تستمر
فنهايتين ده عندك نظامي الان
انا اعتقد انه مثلا لن تاخذ اكثر من يومين
لكن اليومين ديل لانه المدينه مقتظه
تتجاوز تسع ملايين للحصار رسمي و12 مليون
بتاع المنظمات مدينه الخرطوم بمدن الثلاثه
لذلك عدد الموتى حيكون كبير جدا جدا لانه
طبعا كل شيء متوزع وسط الاحياء وسط
الاماكن الحيويه السيد احمد يبقى معي سعود
اليك مره اخرى
اذا مشاهدينا وفي ردود الافعال الدوليه
قالوا زيرو خارجيه الامريكيه خلال لقاء
نظيره البريطاني
قال ان بلاده تشعر بقلق عميق اتجاه
استمرار للاشتباكات في السودان واكدا
اهميه الاتفاق مع الحلفاء على ضروره وقف
الاشتباكات الدائره بلينكن اضاف ان الشعب
السوداني يريد عوده العسكريين لتكناتهم
وان الشعب يتطلع الى دوله ديمقراطيه من
جهته دع ا وزير الخارجيه البريطاني طرفي
الصراع الى اعطاء الاولويه للسلام لانهاء
الازمه
من جانبه طلب وزير الخارجيه البريطاني
جيمس كليفر لي في لقاء مع نظيره الامريكي
بوقف فوري للعنف الدائري في السودان
والعوده الى الحوار
في وقت سابق اليوم اجرينا نقاشا حول الوضع
في السودان وقد تواصلنا مع اصدقائنا في
المنطقه العربيه
وسنستمر بالتواصل وفي نفس الوقت ايضا اود
التاكيد اننا نتفق مع ما قاله الوزير
بلنكن في الدعوه لوقف فوري للعنف والعوده
لمفاوضات تسير باتجاه انتاج حكومه مدنيه
وهذا بالتاكيد هدفنا الاكبر وكلانا سنستمر
بالعمل مع الولايات المتحده واصدقائنا في
افريقيا وفي العالم العربي للوصول الى
السلام والى ديمقراطيه مدنيه
في هذه الاثناء حتى المبعوثه الامميه
للسودان فولكر بيريتس جميع الاطراف على
احترام التزاماتها الدوليه بما في ذلك
ضمان حمايه جميع المدنيين اقل بريتش ان
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع لم
يلتزم امس بوقف القتال الذي اعلن عنه
لاغراض انسانيه الا بشكل جزئي مشيرا الى
خيبه امل شديد جراء تجدد الاشتباكات
معنا من القاهره الدكتور محمد فايز فرحات
مدير مركز الاهرام للدراسات الدكتور محمد
مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره الخارجيه
البريطانيه او عفوا خارجيه سودانيه اليوم
يعني
قالت بان الوضع يجب ان يبقى في السودان
بان الازمه هي سودانيه سودانيه والتسويه
يجب ان تبقى فيما بين السودانيين انفسهم
كيف يمكن ان تفهم هذه التصريحات الدول
الاقليميه الدول المجاوره اعني هنا مصر
لهذه التصريحات
يعني في رايها هذه الرؤيه السودانيه رجعها
الى اكثر من عامل او يفسرها اكثر من عامل
العامل الاول يتعلق بخبره التدخل الدولي
في الاقليم هناك يعني حالات كثيره تدخلت
فيها قوه دوليه في بعض الحالات كان هذا
التدخل العسكري كان بغطاء اممي ومع ذلك
يعني انتهت هذه المشروعات مشروعات التدخل
بعدم وجود اي افق سياسي عدم وجود اي عمليه
سياسيه انتهت المؤسسات الدوله فيها بعض
الحالات بالانهيار الكامل يعني النموذج
الواضح في هذه الحاله
ليبيا ايضا في حالات اخرى كانت المشروعات
الخارجيه وادوار المبعوثين الامميين كانت
ضعيفه الى حد كبير ففي رايي احد العوامل
التي تفسر هذه الرؤيه السودانيه هو خبره
التدخل الخارجي في التعامل مع بعض ازمات
الاقليم العامل الثاني يتعلق بطبيعه
المرحله الحاليه في النظام هناك استقطاب
كبير بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وقوه
اخرى مثل روسيا والصين
وبالتالي في ظل هذه اللحظه يمكن ان يتحول
التدخل الدولي الى توظيف الازمه الداخليه
في السودان لخدمه مصالح دوليه او لخدمه
مصالح مصلحه الصراع القائم بين القوى
الكبرى او على الاقل ان هذا التدخل قد
يؤدي الى تناحر او يؤدي الى خلافات عميقه
بين القوه الدوليه فيما يتعلق بقضيه القوه
السودانيه تراها يعني مساله داخليه العامل
الاخر يتعلق في رايي بان طبيعه الصراع
الحالي في السودان بين المكونين العسكري
الجيش النظامي السوداني من ناحيه
والقوات الدعم السريع اعتقد انه اصبح
مباراه صفريه الجيش هناك توائم هناك يعني
قدره كبيره على ما يبدو لدى او اراده لدى
الجيش السوداني لانهاء مشكله او معضلك
قوات التدخل السريع ووضعها الغريب تاريخيا
داخل النظام في السودان
بالتاكيد التدخل الخارجي خاصه من جانب
القوى الكبرى قد يعرقل هذا المشروع او هذا
الطموح من جانب الجيش السوداني استاذ احمد
البرهان اليوم اعلن حل الدعم السريع اولا
نريد ان نعرف ما الذي يعنيه في هذا
التوقيت الان لماذا تاخر الى اليوم ان كان
متاخرا في التوقيت والخيارات بالنسبه
لحمتي
هو
القرار اصلا يعني كان في طريقه وكانبلور
لانه هذه القوه كما قلنا مره بمراحل
متعدده منذ ان كانت قوه مسانده لا يعني
تسميه لها ولا تابعيه لها لا تتبع لاي جهه
وما كان في قانون باسسها قبل العام 2013
العام 2013
كجنجويت سميت كجنجويت انه مرتبطه باعمال
العنف واعمال
القتل في دارفور وهذا هذا كان سبق سبق
صراحه سبق وجود حميدتي فيها موجود قاده
قبله يعني من نفس المنطقه
بيشكلوا تشكيلات مسلحه تتسمى الجنجويد
لانها بتسرع يعني بيركب الفرس ويقول لك
الجن زنجبيل يعني بيشبهوا نفسهم بانهم هم
يعني شخصيات كذا
السوريه المهم في الموضوع انه هذه القوات
مرض بظروف كثيره تبعت للرئيس السابق
البشير تبعت لجهاز الامن تبعت للشرطه تبعت
لكتفها قانون لم يكن يعني لم يكن تشكيله
واضحا وكما نؤكد ونزيد انه بعد التاسع عشر
يعني 2019
ابريل الثاني عشر من ابريل
السودان جزء وكان هنالك فوضى في هذا في
هذا الملف ملف قوه الدعم السريع تركت تبع
ما تريد لذلك
حلها يعني هذا التركيب المعقد
وثانيا لابد من ذكرها انه يعني كان
بيرى الجيش او قائد الجيش الفريق البرهان
يريد ان يرى يعني كيف ستسير الامور لانك
انت في النهايه تحيل او تربط او كذا هي
طبيعه الصراع اللي حتفرض
النتائج
فاعتقد انه مع اليقين بان هذه القوه يعني
هتنتهي هتنتهي شكلها الماضوي فتم حلها وتم
ترتيب الامور القانونيه اللي هي بتتحدث عن
حل طيب
دكتور محمد التوظيف الازمه السودانيه كما
ذكرت يعني هل هذا متوقع ان يتم توظيف هذه
الازمه كما ذكرت دوليا ان تدخل هناك اطراف
دوليه على هذه الازمه ربما تصب الزيت على
النار لا تحاول المقاربه
يعني اذا اذا تدخلت القوه الدوليه في هذه
اللحظه اعتقد هذا سيكون له انعكاس سلبي
بشكل كبير على الاوضاع الداخليه سواء على
المستوى الامني او على المستوى السياسي
كما نعلم العمليه السياسيه في السودان
تواجه اشكالات وتواجه تحديات كبيره الان
مع اضافه بعد اخر في الازمه في السودان
وهو البعد العسكري في الصراع الحالي اعتقد
ان التدخل القوه الدوليه يعني قد يربك
الامور يعني لاحظنا على سبيل المثال يعني
حديث وزير الخارجيه الامريكي عن ضروره
يعني عوده الجيش الى سكناته العسكريه
والبناء نظام ديمقراطي يعني هذه هذه
القضيه هي القضيه المركزيه في السودان منذ
سنوات لكن القوه السياسيه لم تستطع الوصول
الى هذا الهدف وبالتالي طرح هذا الهدف من
جانب الولايات المتحده او وزير الخارجيه
او حديث الوزير الخارجيه الامريكيه عن هذه
القضيه الان اعتقد انها لا تتناسب مع
طبيعه اللحظه الراهنه لا لا يمكن احد
اهميه بناء النظام الديمقراطي لكن القضيه
ان بناء مثل هذه النظام او الوصول الى هذا
الهدف يحتاج الى بيئه عديده وجود ازدواجيه
في السلطه اعتقد او في ازدواجيه في
المؤسسات العسكريه داخل السودان في راي لم
يتناسب مع بناء توافق واسع داخل السودان
ولم يكن شرطا مواتيا لنجاح العمليه
السياسيه بدليل ما حدث لا كان يعني قوات
الدعم السريع تحولت الى قوه في مواجهه
الوصول او التوقيع على المسوده او التوقيع
على الصيغه النهائيه للقوات
الاطاري
النقطه المهمه التي اريد التاكيد على ان
هناك فجوه كبيره بين الخطاب الدوله وبين
الواقع المعقد في السودان في رايي ان ما
يحدث الان في السودان هو حل احدى المعضلات
التاريخيه الموجوده في السودان منذ يعني
نشات ما عرف به قوه الجانجويد ثم تحولت
الى قوه الدعم السريع
حد حتى تعامل القوه السياسيه في السودان
مع الازمه السودانيه اعتقد انه مازال اسير
له بعض القوى او بعض المداخل التقليديه
يعني ليس من المناسب النظر الى
استاذ احمد
السيناريو الارجح للازمه الان المتوقع في
دقيقه
ليس هنالك الجيش السوداني استعاد كما ذكرت
في اول حديث ثقته والقمان من تبعه دلوقتي
احنا بنتحدث عن ايام قليله تفصل بين
نهايه المعركه الاساسيه نهايه المعركه
الاساسيه ايش هي تنظيف جيوب والمناطق
الموجود فيها
موجوده فيها قوه الدعم السريع في العاصمه
وفي المدن الكبرى دلوقتي التحدي الوحيد ان
لا تحدث
البشريه ان لا تحدث خسائر بشريه الكثير
يعني قضوا ولا يعرف لهم الان سبيلا للوصول
وسيقضي كثيرون لكن هذه المعركه ما عندها
طريقه يعني ما في طريقه توقف في منتصف
الطريق مهما
دولي اقليمي ده كله لانه المعركه خلاص
وصلت الى ذروه ايوه ذروه وزير وداخل الجيش
نفسه من اداره يعني انه اداره هذه المعركه
اذا لم تحسم ستظل الامور عالقه وستظلل
المشاكل القابله للتفجر مره اخرى لذلك لا
بد من
تنتهي المعركه وامام الجيش السوداني ارى
وارى بوضوح انه خلال يومين لن يكون هنالك
لن تكون اشكرك السريعه احمد القرشي الصحفي
المتخصص في الشان السوداني شكرا جزيلا لك
من القاهره الدكتور محمد فايز فرحات مدير
مركز الاهرام شكرا جزيلا لك تغطيتنا
انتهت في هذه الساعه الان الى الزميل طالب
كنعان ليكمل هذه التغطيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات